hablemos de la regulación post
transcripcional qué es la regulación qué
ocurre una vez que el adn ha sido
transcrito en arn me he dibujado este
pequeño esquema que muestra que una
cadena de adn tiene una cadena de arn
correspondiente y posteriormente en nm
en un momento explicaré qué significan
los diferentes colores y palabras una
vez que el adn es transcrito por la arn
polimerasa en la cadena de adn
correspondiente esta cadena de adn
necesita lo que yo llamo un buen corte
de pelo y luego ponerse algo de ropa
protectora antes de que pueda dejar la
comodidad del núcleo para su gran debut
en el citoplasma en la forma de un
mensajero completamente procesado o una
cadena de arne m ahora tengamos en
cuenta que esta forma de regulación
ocurre sólo en eucariotas y esta
modificación también ayuda a estabilizar
el inm para protegerlo de la degradación
prematura antes de que se traduzca en
una proteína como podemos ver aquí el
adn se transcribe uno a uno
base por base en rn y podemos ver que
hay secciones del arn que finalmente
logran llegar al arn terminado estos
segmentos cortos que se denominan exones
son las secuencias que codifican el
producto proteico definitivo después
tenemos segmentos cortos de arn no
codificantes que se llaman intrones
estos se cortan o empalman este sería el
corte de pelo que mencioné anteriormente
y se logra mediante una gran entidad
molecular llamada explicó soma él es
precioso más se une a cada lado de un
intro no hace que el intro no forme un
círculo y luego los separa después liga
los dos extremos cortados de los exones
expuestos y una manera fácil de recordar
que secuencia son exones y cuáles son
intrones es que los exones salen al
exterior del núcleo y los intrones
permanecen en el interior del núcleo
ahora a pesar de que el arn ha
conseguido su corte de pelo todavía no
está listo para abandonar el núcleo
tiene que tomar lo que se llama un cap o
casquete 5 prima y una cola de poli
tres primas que son estas cosas que
acabo de mencionar un cap 5 prima se
refiere a cambios en el extremo 5 prima
del arn m y recuerden que este es el
extremo de fosfato de las bases de
nucleótidos en el rn m así que eso es
cómo podemos mantener los dos extremos
rectos formar el cap en el extremo 5
prima convierte este extremo del aire nm
en un extremo de 3 prima mediante un
enlace de 5 prima a 5 prima que
básicamente protege al nm de las ex onu
clases que degradan el aire extraño el
cap también promueve la unión a
ribosomas para la traducción y ayuda a
la regulación de la exportación nuclear
del rm ahora la cola polea va en el otro
extremo el extremo 3 prima del arn que
tiene el grupo hidroxilo terminal a qué
me refiero cuando digo cola poli a bueno
la cola poli am se refiere a la poli
adén y la acción en la que se agregan
múltiples mono fosfatos de adenosina o
bases de adenina que actúan como un
amortiguador para la sexo
gracias para aumentar la vida media del
inm y nuevamente protegerlo de la
degradación el propósito de la cola
polilla es realmente muy similar al del
cap
5 prima que es básicamente proteger
contra la degradación ayudará a promover
la traducción y regular la exportación
nuclear la cola polea también hace una
cosa más y es ayudar con la terminación
de la transcripción de la arn polimerasa
que transcribe el arn mensajero la poli
adenina ciones catalizada por una enzima
llamada poli adenilato polimerasa que
como los mono fosfatos de adenosina usa
trifosfato de adenosina como sustrato y
la cola de paul ya se construye hasta
que tiene aproximadamente 250
nucleótidos de largo en general el caps
5 prima y la cola poli a ayudan a
estabilizar el arn para la traducción
ese es el punto clave a recordar de este
vídeo
una vez que el arnés ha formado el cap y
la cola y se han retirado los intrones
ahora está listo para salir del núcleo y
ser traducido en una proteína
finalmente hay un tipo más de regulación
de arn llamada edición de rn que es un
proceso que resulta en la variación de
secuencia en la molécula de arn y es
catalizada por varias enzimas la edición
de arn es relativamente rara y estos
eventos pueden incluir la inserción
eliminación y sustitución de nucleótidos
dentro de la molécula de arn evitada
ahora una de estas enzimas se llama
adenosina deaminasa que actúa sobre el
arn o enzima a dar que convierte los
residuos específicos de adenosina en y
nothing a de una molécula de arn por de
samín acción hidro lítica otro tipo de
edición se llama citosina de esa amenaza
que actúa sobre la rn o sedar que
implica la de samín acción de la
citosina alhaurina por la citadina de
esa minas a la edición de aire n se está
estudiando ampliamente en relación con
las enfermedades infecciosas porque el
proceso de edición altera las enzimas
virales y su función es un concepto
nuevo y emocionante en la regulación
post transcripción al